ce chiffre mais connu plus de huit
pompiers sur 10 sont des pompiers
volontaires menuisier agriculteurs ou
commerciaux ils ont choisi de donner de
leur temps pour sauver des vies problème
certaines casernes en milieu rural
manque aujourd'hui cruellement de bras
dans un instant justement parlera
recrutement avec mon invité mais d'abord
à quoi ressemble la vie d'un
sapeur-pompier volontaire pourquoi
s'engage-t-il ellen chapelet on a
rencontré deux en loir et cher solène et
son mari sont tous les deux pompiers lui
professionnelle elle volontaire et dans
leur maison de saint georges sur cher
quelques détails trahissent cette
passion qui les unit à 29 ans solène
déjà une longue expérience dans le
volontariat puisque elle a intégré dès
16 ans le centre de secours de sa
commune cette maman technico commercial
est la seule femme de sa caserne qui
compte 21 autres volontaires pour elle
les pompiers c'est le week end où les
nuits de 19h à 6h du matin dès que le
bip retentit elle doit se rendre le plus
vite possible au centre pour s'équiper
et partir en intervention
une passion commune autres selon elle
qu'est ce qui me plaît tomba déjà le
l'assistance à personne tout simplement
être là pour les autres ça je pense que
toute façon c'est une vocation
voilà l'ambiance caserne aussi qui est
vraiment très importante pour le
bien-être surtout en tant que femme
c'est vraiment une deuxième famille
auquel on se sent vraiment bien et ouais
non c'est très très important et puis et
on a envie de continuer envie de
progresser encore et encore quand le bip
sonne et que mes enfants doit il partir
oui maman elle est partie au feu voilà
ouais quand même par rapport aux enfants
ça fait une petite fierté il faut avouer
autres cases et 1,1 du loir-et-cher
celle de saint-amand-longpré elle compte
vingt volontaires dont flavien 31 ans
cela fait déjà quinze ans qu'il donne de
son temps pour venir en aide aux
habitants des communes limitrophes
on compte ici près de 350 interventions
par an des chiffres qui ne baisse pas
d'où l'importance d'avoir des
volontaires pour répondre rapidement aux
différentes d'urgence
si la personne a certainement admettons
abloy le savent directement par le biais
de la console et ils sont obligés
d'appeler une autre caserne qui est
forcément la plus proche mais qui va
demander quand même plus de temps si
c'est une intervention
mettons qui a 200 mètres en face de la
caserne forcément 6 et vendôme montoire
qui forcément ça demande un peu plus de
temps c'est pourquoi le mieux c'est
d'avoir un maximum de pompiers dans
chaque caserne pour pouvoir subvenir à
toutes ces interventions le loir-et-cher
compte aujourd'hui 1621 sapeurs pompiers
volontaires et 208 professionnels des
hommes et des femmes qui ont choisi de
se mettre au service des autres
quoi qu'il en coûte